The electrons shuffling around inside our
computers move pretty fast, theoretically
their top speed in silicon is up to 100,000
meters per second.
Which is good because the faster they can
move, the faster chips can do calculations,
the faster I can refresh twitter.
But there will always be something faster.
Light.
Why don’t we use photons in computers instead
of electrons?
We already use photons for communication;
fiber optic cables are what keep the globe’s
computers interconnected as they hurtle data
around at light speed.
But when it comes time to process that data,
we convert light to electrons and run them
through transistors.
The conversion uses energy and electrons are
comparatively slow, so researchers are exploring
how to build light based transistors instead.
Transistors are the fundamental building block
of your computer’s central processing unit.
They’re basically nanoscale switches that
will either stop current or let it flow.
It’s important that a transistor’s output
can act as the input for the next transistor.
Actually it has to be able to send the current
on to at least two transistors for logic signals
to propagate, and it has to preserve that
signal quality to keep errors to a minimum.
We have made optical switches, but for one
reason or another they don’t work as a replacement
for the silicon transistors we use in electronics,
like because the output signal is a different
wavelength than the input, making controlling
the next switch in line difficult.
Or the design for the switch is too big, in
the micron scale instead of the nanoscale,
so gains in speed come at the expense of size.
Or the design requires a cloud of supercooled
atoms, which isn’t exactly practical.
Even though scientists have been trying since
the 60s, an optical transistor that can replace
an electrical one has never materialized.
So instead of using our current approach to
computing and substituting light in for electrons,
we might have to try something entirely different.
Like trying to build a photonic chip that
mimics how a human brain performs calculations.
Scientists at MIT have built a chip that uses
beams of light sent through channels of silicon
to mimic a neural network.
The beams split and combine and travel at
different speeds as the silicon is heated
and cooled.
Brighter beams represent bigger numbers, and
as these beams split, combine, and interfere
with each other, their brightness changes,
effectively performing several small multiplication
problems lightning fast.
They’ve applied this photonic chip to train
a neural network to understand vowel sounds
and have had modest success.
They think they can improve their results
dramatically by making a purpose built system,
instead of the jury-rigged proof of concept
they tested.
But given how optical computing has historically
failed to live up to expectations, skeptics
aren’t holding their breath.
Before we see an all light chip, we’ll probably
see hybrid optoelectronic systems that take
advantage of light’s ability to transmit
data quickly across large distances.
But until transistors reach their lower size
limit and can’t improve any more, it looks
like we’ll be relying on slow old electrons
to do the mathematical heavy lifting.
We haven’t found our way to the future of
computing -- yet -- so make sure you’re
ready when we finally get there, by starting
your very own website with Domain dot com.
Domain dot com is awesome, affordable, reliable,
and has all the tools you need to build a
new website.
They can fulfill all your website needs.
They offer dot com and dot net domain names,
and intuitive website builders.
They have over three hundred domain extensions
to fit your needs, from dot ninja to dot dog,
to dot love!
Take that first step in creating an identity
online and visit domain dot com.
Why would transistors have a lower size limit?
Blame quantum weirdness.
Trace explains why we might one day ditch
silicon here.Fun fact: there’s a disagreement
whether light based computers or quantum computers
are the future, but thanks to the nature of
light it’s possible future computers could
be both!Thanks for watching